oh okay fine whoa okay then well hello
hi I'm Naruto Inge I'm now redoing I'm
doing the now I can actually work okay
then hi oh god damn it oh wow switches
directions what why did someone program
a game in half use why didn't they just
make another game this is awesome
wow this so cool I'm riding a cloud
I'm freaking Goku yeah my brain run
invisible floor again with less stupid I
mean I have ample amounts of stupid in
my life so let's just meander a [ __ ] I
know what the problem is ample baggage
alright bye son
I guess you're not dead but you know
maybe this is better drop it off at
babysitting school Oh
the concept of doing a race [ __ ] you
buddy
[ __ ] that pants and [ __ ] these more
melons or anything I like to do it my
old agents [ __ ] a lot of melons too hard
for you [ __ ] damn it's too hard for my
son
highs concern listen I think this is
gonna be the one so long as I super my
way whoops man my Superman my way into
death titties all right the problem in
the last one who said my angular
trajectory was all [ __ ] Spock all
right this time I'm going to use the
circular orbital trajectory of complete
nutter scientific [ __ ] I think this
is gonna be the one [ __ ] your father
[ __ ] your father pushing forward like a
baby
titties [ __ ] god damn it oh this might
be the one first just before firsts okay
so apparently even in death I still
can't stop twerking okay I stopped never
mind there's gonna be something tasty
second is my shower of blood any
indication of my success 80% impossible
poor girl good thing they're being more
realistic though
good thing we're they're being a bit
more realistic about my chances hey mama
if I get to space go to hell and now I
shall hump you for all of eternity as
this harpoon jackhammers into my
butthole that my massive fatness I'll
probably walk how about this if I belly
flop into it wasn't ready you can't just
say surviving well fine aha watch this
[ __ ] oh yeah you think that's gonna
kill me
ow my balls but I'm okay watch this
success feels like death take some of
this how about over this that you only
got my he only got my head haha [ __ ]
your mother [ __ ] your father's oh [ __ ]
my heart what if I just lay down until
the right moment to spring up to action
well [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah bruh
yeah look at me look at me look at me
I'm like the greatest that ever lived
welcome to death ball yeah like I said
before death - these frickin melons and
those pumpkins Pixar
I've tried to survive through drink by
inserting the bottle up my rectum into
fight you wanna fire me oh my god
I'm less of a ninja and more just an
extreme meat grinder take some of that
that's what you get for messing with a
ninja the neighborhood watch oh my god
oh god ma'am ma'am ma'am just ma'am it's
not worth it I know dancing on the
corpse of Santa is something that you've
always wanted to do with your life but
please well you don't have to worry
about a thing because I'm dead and your
legs broke so together we make two
halves of a whole idiot slow down
words slow now time in my vocabulary bro
I also left my son behind hey maybe
that's just what I've been trying to do
when I go on these weird worlds where
people ride walls for some goddamn
reason
ow my everything yes what are we good
joke I get nothing huh yeah uh yeah just
because I'm drunk doesn't mean that you
get to take my points away from me or my
balls
candy ragdoll fall Oh whatever [ __ ] you
like candy anyway I don't eat sugars
well this is moderately disappointing
just like everything else I've done in
my life
oh boy median mmm and mmm that's gonna
be tasty and delicious once I get the
diabetes coursing through my veins yep
Oh Pro level Wow well I'm already
started bleeding on pro level I think I
can retire yay that was hard
dead settlement I don't know what this
means is this how the divorce is gonna
put me and Timmy finally get rid of the
[ __ ] wife oh yeah whatever
go away birdie you didn't wear weren't
welcome here anyway
just me and my son's favorite pastime of
riding the electrical wire well that's
fun while it lasted let's go find out
why the neighbors stay dead settlement
you have one chance oh [ __ ] god damn it
all right son you dangle your arms to
your heart's content and we'll keep
going we'll get in here oh hello well I
made it apparently our one chance paid
off don't know where we're going now
seems to be a neighborhood two tree
houses which is the equally bizarre
god edsel me but ok I'll take it what is
this - well I bought a body slam you
into the next century a silhouette at
nothingness and I want to win cuz I'm
going super fast and it's always gonna
turn out well for the fly vasectomy good
God person machine oh it's torturing me
why is it torturing me oh I'm not
tortured
I don't feel tortured at all this is
actually quite relaxing gives me a lot
of lumbar support well nevermind that
I'm picking obliterated my pelvis is
entirely rambled hello we're there
bottles of booze here well I'm going
into this the wrong way
[Music]
happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye